this is one of the most iconic sequences
in all of superhero movies
our old buddies at scanline actually
render out individual particles for all
the mist here wow crazy stuff that is
crazy stuff all right i'm just gonna say
there's two visual effects happening is
samuel l jackson's go tcg
thanks to raycon for sponsoring this
episode stick around at the end to see
how you can get 15 off for the
holidays hey what's up welcome back to
another episode of visual effects artist
react today we are looking at spider-man
2 and spider-man 2 and spider-man 2.
that's right we are looking at all of
the spider-man 2's today because
you know spider-man 2 is one of my
favorite movies and spider-man 2 is
arguably also one of the worst
spider-man films dude i i just watched
spider-man 2 last night and it is way
worse than i could have ever possibly
imagined but the effects are cool and
we're going to look at some of those
today let's kick things off with a
little clip
from spider-man 2.
wait we going straight into spider-man 2
let's let's talk about spider-man 2.
anybody here take shop class
this is an incredible scene objectively
yeah this scene is a perfect scene those
tentacles look pretty real throughout
that whole thing they do if i was
watching this movie now like let's say
this we came out last year i would guess
the tentacles are 100 cg for the entire
thing oh yeah but they're not in fact
they are practical far more often than
you think you might think oh it's just
like little close-up shots so i got the
little like things going
but they actually had 16 puppeteers on
set for any shots that had all four arms
in motion i believe it so like four
people per arm yeah also so you know
those little like guys on the end have
so much emotion like they can be focused
and be open they can be like you know
punchy in order to control all of those
different things they actually built
this like throne they call it and they
have all these sticks like foot pedals
and one dude controls all the different
articulating fingers on these oh no way
oh yeah look at that
but take for example the bandana coming
off of alfred molina's i was actually
wondering about that because it's like
okay you can have the little digital guy
it looks pretty good but it actually
grabs on to his bandage and pulls it off
what you're seeing here on screen is
exactly what they're getting in camera
on the day i believe it but what i'm
seeing here is that cg is very hard to
do
specular highlights that are out of
focus and sharp and this has it very
well like look at the tentacles on the
left there in the background like look
at all the hot white spots there they're
perfectly sharp they're out of focus in
a very natural feeling way if they were
to do that cg it'd be a little bit
softer it wouldn't quite be so sharp and
plus when those things like open up and
retract there's a little bit of like
gradingness to it
i can
yeah like it's on like a rough track
that's something that you would never
animate or like yeah i mean if you did
animate you'd be bragging about it all
day
so this right here i think is very easy
to say is
fully cg tentacles because of their
motion they're moving in a way that you
can't quite puppet very easily there's a
lot of things happening also if you look
at the cloth dangling on the arms that
before it falls off it looks pretty cg
oh yeah yeah i didn't even think about
the cloth look at that you're totally
right it's well done though it's very
well done it looks good this is 2004.
rendering is coming along they're able
to make things look pretty photo real
but something like that fabric not only
requires a certain level of detail that
they probably didn't bother with in the
shock because it's so fast but you have
a lot of like translucency and the way
light works through fabric it's just
it's really tricky the biggest thing
though is that the motion here like at
the end of the day it's like animation
is what gives away things being cg
and it's not that the motion is
unrealistic to a certain extent it's
that it moves so fast and it's so wild
and free that you wouldn't be able to
puppet something like that
hand her over of course let's take a
look at the shot when they're on the
side of the building so this here i'm
pretty sure is practical to a degree yes
the arms i think are probably cg because
they're piercing into the brick wall
this is that easy
is also cg the building was cg
everything in this shot is cg right now
looks great i mean it looks dg but it
also looks great
it's the trench coat most of the time
for me it's it's it's your like 2004
cloth stim revisiting it with these
goggles that we have on right now it's
like you can tell but there's something
kinetic about it that just works really
well that
you don't notice that it's vfx just
right off the bat you know i got to say
ren it's got to be something with the
lighting they seem to have just nailed
like the texture work it's it's a
combination of like detail where you can
have the camera up close to the wall but
also far back the whole thing still
reads is there do you know is there some
secret sauce they're doing for the
buildings here yes there is
basically they had a real practical set
that they built and they did a lot of
photographic plate capture so it's not
quite photogrammetry you know they're
not quite doing photo scanning but
they're doing a lot of pictures in a 3d
space
oh
the ian hubert thing
yeah
they take a picture of it and then they
yeah buildings and stuff like this is
very easy to do in cg because you get
some textures you get some simple
lighting you don't really have too many
bounces interior cg is harder to do
because you have your light ray hitting
your thing then hitting the ground and
then hitting the thing again then
hitting the ground again and it takes a
lot longer to render the more bounces
you have but when you're outside you
have a ray coming in hitting your thing
and then it bounces away goodbye some
things i also want to touch on here is
the animation so the animation's great
like it's awesome and they did a bunch
of development research before they
actually went out and shot these scenes
they looked at octopuses right doc ock
let's look at octopuses however a couple
issues arose one when octopuses are
underwater they're kind of weightless
and it's not really the right look for
the arms and they decide that they
actually kind of want more of a bone or
jointed look for doc ox arms here in the
movie so they're still flexible but it's
much more inspired by a snake than it is
an octopus interesting i see that sure
however they also took inspiration from
uh an octopus that if you cut off an
octopus's tentacle the tentacle will
keep performing the last like action
that it was given from the octopus's
brain oh my god that's jacked up so
that's why doc ock's arms have their own
like thought they use that to help
inform the character and how they're
always like influencing his thought and
kind of doing their own thing and all
that research and all that practice
and probably all the puppeteering really
added up to animators being able to make
really informed
intelligent characterized motion for doc
hawk which makes these cool scenes even
cooler
this is one of the most iconic sequences
in all of superhero movies period yeah i
mean we've talked about this before in
summon react 2 but
this is a good action scene partially
because it's always setting up little
mini problems that require clever
solutions when he's on the ground and
he's losing the train let's skate along
the ground pulling with my web to drive
myself like that's super clever it can
only be done by spider-man that's just
one of the hundreds of cool little
problems he has to solve throughout this
entire sequence of course the biggest
problem is how do you stop the train the
thing i remember from this sequence
though is that like he's trying so hard
to hold on to those webs
that he ends up buckling the train
itself you know
so they had a real practical bent in
version of the train in addition to a
regular version of the train we don't
really see too much of the actual train
car buckling so like we see a little bit
of stuff bursting and then we cut to a
new shot and we already see it crushed
in
that face is a little ridiculous though
yeah i mean i'd love to see your face
when you stop a train
i think like really summarizing this
spider-man 2 it really just comes down
to expert craftsmanship in the intent
of what's going into the shot you know
it's not just like throw a bunch of cg
at it it's like they know when to use
stuff practically they know when to make
it digital how to put it all together
and just the choreography and the
animation just it's so well thought out
and planned the movie is also super
cohesive in that even the action scenes
feel like they're set in the same movie
with the same actors and the same
director as the dialogue seems and
granted you know there's a bunch of
talented people that are informing the
action design and the visual effects and
all that kind of stuff but it's there's
a lot of modern movies where your
dialogue scenes and your action scenes
are just completely different styles and
might as well be made by completely two
different directors probably because
they are you know whereas this movie
just it feels really cohesive and
everything feels true to the story and
it all serves the story that's being
told
so this is the opening sequence to the
amazing spider-man 2 it's the second
sequel reboot
spider-man 2 2. so i watched this movie
last night and i have to say this is one
of the worst movies i've ever seen
it is so bad
has some of the dumbest writing i've
ever seen in a movie electro is the
dumbest written character i've ever seen
so having said all that this movie
actually does do some things with visual
effects that i think are well done and
namely i think the web physics and the
suit are very well done in this movie
here's the thing spider-man always looks
like a like a smooth gumby
type of guy like spider-man when he's
flying around and he's cg he looks like
he's just buttery smooth exactly in this
movie
they intentionally made the suit a
little looser a little more loose
fitting so that they can get the
wrinkles and the rippling of the suit oh
my gosh yeah the animation is pretty
nice this shot right here i love it yeah
like it goes around the building on the
right right here that's really cool
actually yeah this is a really cool
looking spider man you're designing this
suit it's like all right what's your
reference like i mean it's skydiving
right that's that's your that's your
reference that's your visual reference
for what spider-man looks like or his
suit looks like when it's going through
the air so i'm i'm imagining like even
if you're wearing tight like spandex or
yoga pants or whatever and you go
skydiving it's still going to ripple
because you're just going that fast look
you can even almost see like underwear
lines it makes such a freaking
difference like even though i see stuff
from the new spider-man 2 and i like you
you look at the suit and you're like but
it's like literally mr smoothie or
whatever mr
no but really like you're like you're
like am i watching this at like 240p or
is this that like 1080 like you can't
tell if there's like oh maybe it's just
a wash of compression that's why i don't
see any details like no there's there
isn't a lot of detail i think the
amazing spider-man really nailed the
look of a spider-man suit because it
feels like a suit you know it doesn't
feel like his skin is just spider-man
colored my complaints about this movie
are more about like the filmmaking and
storytelling and writing the visuals
overall are pretty dang good and then we
get to this end sequence here and it
just kind of like dude i'm getting
lawnmower man vibes
the idea to make jamie foxx this like
freaking blue man group dude the weird
kind of dr manhattan glow is just it
doesn't it looks 100 cg it does not look
like it'd be filmed with the real camera
and the thing that sticks out to me is
that like you don't buy that this is a
real place it looks more like a video
game level the way we move the way the
camera moves the way everything's
directed and acted the scenario itself
it feels like you're watching a cg
animation
don't you hate when you turn and you see
a car
man if only you could fly then you
wouldn't be hit by cars
why do you just slide like a foot higher
it's not like he didn't see it coming he
turns and sees the car coming this
really speaks to the dichotomy of like
big budget movies that always irks me
which is you literally have cutting edge
incredibly sophisticated cg with like
inventive problem solving going on
and it's just you know millions of
dollars and thousands of people working
on it and then the best they can do for
emma stone's arrival is just
she hits them with the car because he's
floating two feet off the ground he goes
it's like you got so sophisticated and
advanced with one thing and the other
one has about as much creative effort as
like you know a five-minute idea and a
boardroom meeting so moral of the story
spider-man two had a lot of good things
going for it and writing was not one of
them yeah a lot of great technical
achievements
oh my gosh oh snap
dude
i love you guys i had to just interrupt
dude we got black panther himself here
right now keep watching
now from a story perspective i do think
the tom hall and spider-man movies are
excellent i agree i think they're very
good movies i think spider-man 2 also
is really cool because it does have the
most meta villain in any of them because
mysterio is literally wearing a motion
capture suit so what's what's the design
called sterpinsky the serpinsky pattern
it's essentially a fractal of triangles
yeah
and it's very good for showing
orientation because you have three
points of a triangle and as it moves
around and if you know the length of
each side you can kind of determine the
actual relative angle of those triangles
and when you have enough of them over a
bodysuit it's very easy to track
something and so that's become such a
big thing in the industry you know ninja
turtles had them you always see like
these dudes in these mocap suits on set
so i think it became enough of an inside
joke from the filmmakers that they're
like all right he seems to be a bit of a
vfx artist so let's give him a vfx
artist costume i mean yeah it's just
it's illusion holograms you know that so
yeah it makes sense for the story we've
already looked at the whole dream
sequence in a previous episode linked
down in the description check it out
[Applause]
our old buddies at scanline did this
scene
our old buddies and it's because there's
water in it ah yeah yeah so scanline
they're known for a ton of water because
they've got their own custom water
software so they they did it for this
and usually you're doing water
simulations and you add like volumetric
mist basically yeah
to to kind of create like the micro
particles but they they brute forced it
in this whole system
to actually render out individual
particles for all the myths here
so we're talking millions of particles
like those aren't those they're not
volumetric simulations they're they're
like actual particle sims so the reason
we're talking about like the the mist
being particles as being such a big deal
is because you might do something like
that using voxels and voxels let you do
fluid simulations like you know smoke
and fire and things like that and a
voxel is a volumetric pixel it's
basically a tiny cube and then you give
properties that cube does it have smoke
in it how much uh you know if you're
shooting a light ray through this volume
of voxels what happens is the light gray
goes into it as it goes deeper and
deeper doesn't lose energy does it
bounce back out in a different direction
but you could also get the brute force
throughout having millions of particles
your ray can just come in hit a particle
and bounce out some rays will go all the
way in before they hit a particle some
rays will bounce off the surface and hit
the particle you know different
particles the way out they'll take on
different colors and you can do that all
through ray tracing which is single ray
bouncing through things as opposed to
taking up properties as steps or marches
through things crazy stuff that is crazy
stuff
you're a very difficult person to
contact spider-man so in this next scene
i want you guys to guess where the vfx
are happening this is just a normal
dialogue scene
is samuel l jackson's go t cg
all right i'm just gonna say uh there's
two visual effects happening
let me guess his gun is cg yep wait for
real yeah he's holding a stick with tape
on it
he's not even in the room i was actually
gonna mention that
they filmed these two halves of the
conversation separately he's on her own
screen dang it i was gonna guess that
he's not even there no they're like the
biggest scheduling thing probably
probably a scheduling thing when you're
working with like big name actors like
this and you're having to coordinate
things for a whole movie shoot but like
their schedules just don't line up so
you can have both of them in the same
spot at the same time especially for
something like this where this is like
just a day shoot it's so so so so funny
when you it's like the simplest of
scenes basically a guy sitting in chair
talking to another person in a room and
it's just yeah we
we comped a man
they were never actually
marvel for you
it looks great you would never suspect
it you would never think of a single
thing you need you wouldn't even look at
the gun in the hand and go like oh
that's fake it's like no just it's
totally invisible
guys the holiday is quickly approaching
and thanks to today's sponsor raycon
i've got the perfect gift idea for you
right here the everyday earbuds that's
right because today's sponsor is raycon
so i'm actually being a lot like
spider-man right now because he has his
ears blocked out from the wind with a
mask same way as i've got my ears
blocked out from the noise isolating fit
when i'm ripping down the street on a
one wheel it's very windy so these
things help isolate that sound away so
that i don't get that wind noise when
i'm trying to enjoy my music they come
with their own charging case now these
ones are the fancy blue ones but they
come in five different colors as well so
let's say you got the wrong color that
sucks i'm sorry well guess what you can
return these for free with free shipping
as well if you or someone you know wants
some earbuds well guess what you know
what's better than having high quality
premium earbuds having them at an
affordable price so you don't even have
to like splurge to get them some
wireless earbuds you can get them
something else too because of their
price all you gotta do is click the link
in the description or go to byracon.com
corridor crew and use the code holiday
and you will get 15 off anything on the
site thanks again to raycon let's get
back to the spider-mans the spider-man
spider-man boys
spider-boys to men
you guys want danny gonzalez the big
famous youtuber well he worked here at
corridor like a few months before that
happened
and while he was here he made a video
with peter called not spider-man and we
never released it so we just kind of
held on to it we re-watched it recently
i was like hey this actually isn't that
bad we should just put it out
so it's out now yeah on the quarter
channel you can go watch it right now
it's pretty funny if you're sick of
everyone being spider-man
this is not the video for you
[Laughter]
spider-man is great and all but what if
it was a little bit more rated r well
guess what we did that and it's coming
out on this channel tomorrow so
subscribe for that
oh and if you subscribe to
quarterdigital.com you can watch
spider-man rated right now because it
comes out early on our website as all
videos do yeah without ads
if you had to rank spider-man 2s what
would you put spider-man two first
second round oh definitely spider-man
two at the time yeah oh yeah easy easy
but dude spider-man 2 is not only one of
the worst spider-man movies of all time
it's easily one of the worst movies
are you excited for spider-man 3 dude
i'm very excited i'm pretty excited for
the new spider-man 2.